hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the caption relief extraction
and purification of NGS grade DNA and
RNA from ffpe tissue samples I am junior
walker black groups will be your
moderator for today's events we are
delighted screening of this educational
web seminar presented by rappers and
sponsored like robots for more
information please visit Guevara skinks
com we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive we
encourage you to ask questions dramione
X you can submit questions by typing in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on range you donate button at
the lower left of the presentation
window we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can you can enlarge the
fried rado by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you have any
technical problems joining or sharing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speakers guillaume de rass PhD
product manager kavarna doctors young
man's been years of experience in
protocol and consumables development in
the field of sample preparation for
molecular biology recently dr. durán has
worked on developing a DNA and RNA
extraction solution or ffpe tissue by
utilizing colossus packages and captives
focused acoustics technology and true
extract purification kit doctor Dora
fractions with what type of qualities
required so use DNA RNA contain the
amplifier most library preparation just
pausing technique with Aaron orange
piece of prime importance to observe in
suburban life whether the pavement guess
not green haha na of I quality makes a
very little demon world is in the
country and when working with SSD
samples begins to requirement is often a
challenge but when your infraction
technique is able to do so you library
will pass QC test and your sequin
sigmetrics ice cover a uniformity we
drastically improve so today webinar
will be slitting will be split in four
parts first I will put on the challenge
when working with a face numbers then I
will discuss how active part in removal
with sa can otherwise most of them I
will then present data showing how you
can achieve ng8 gray weak acid
extraction with Si and finally I will
use a full workflow evil by provides for
nucleic acid extraction from a thief
numbers so what r fic samples if this
instance of formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded this is mated that
there is more than 1 billion is an
instant purchase worldwide and actually
the most common method for precise
preserving 30 tissue samples for
clinical diagnostic and research so it
preserved the tissue mythology which
does not been designed for use in
molecular analysis and from nucleic acid
extraction from SSP will enable to
correlate digit state with tissue
mythology with the genotype from the DNA
of them gene expression
when working with RNA so it's an
excellent resource for new generic
inside using my generation comes in with
nucleic acid extraction has been highly
variable and time consuming when working
from FFPE samples so there are many
challenge associated with FF is numbers
and so they are related to both the
processing at the storage if these
numbers are highly crosslinked so indeed
some a date with react with proteins
creating a 3d network that's also
causing two nucleic acids some of these
costings can remain after the
purification and affect the don't swim
electical steps it is especially true if
ash deeper a physician treatment has
degrade the proteins into peptides and
before the call think we were thorough
making it much less efficient so
processing and storage conditions may
also differ sample two samples and
degrade nucleic acids start embedding
protocols will require a hedging and
there is no standardized embedding work
flow between institutions so we'll see
lacerations between samples and also the
nucleus it in tissue blood tenth grade
during storage and this is especially
visible with them when you're looking
for RNA extraction so what is the
traditional workflow from nucleus
extraction from the fifties numbers so
first you need to start with a partial
removal so it's possible you often use
like some hash organic solvent like
xylene or something like a little
neither like mineral oils or psych
resolve it can take from five to Hudson
aware then you have to rehydrate the
tissue it's also passive with multiple
solvent water activation you can then
digest the tissue you ready proteinase k
sometimes other enzyme al use digestion
time with vary greatly did any of the
protocol but you can be up to 70 72
hours then you have to cause link
revealed cross-linked by heat
different operator from 80 to 90 °c and
up to two hours did any of the protocols
and then we go to the DNA extraction
purification usually done by Colin
precipitation magnetic beads or even
some final crawls on protocols so
overall it's a complex workflow up to
three to four days with many variables
and at the end the output as mini
limitation when you're looking for high
quality education you're getting low
quality because also step with organic
solvents heating you have mini
degradation to the DNA RNA particular
complex meaning 10 aflutter variations
right arrow to the other requirement for
organic solvents time consuming up to 72
hours and overall poor attraction or
disability one sample could yield good
general and another sample some good way
to ina our DNA so the critical need our
egg list for a new method to accommodate
sensitivity and creative requirement of
NGS days analyzes so true extract is a
short approach to nuclear acid
extraction how much three samples you
can see on the slide the orbit workflow
but the first time I would like to focus
on the key films of to extract the
active passing removal and tissue
hydration with a focus acoustic and I
will start by presenting quickly a fight
so I say stands for adaptive focus
acoustics it's a unique approach to park
in removal tissue hydration and
homogenization from AC tissue samples so
first we present what TJ technology and
then discussed how you can apply sa to
FF a tissue DNA or RNA extraction waffle
so I say is based on highly developed
technologies which have been optimized
for biomolecular processing so one of
the techno technology is a particular
croissant it's little Trixie used to
break down kidney and get your gal
stones another technique is generally a
glow stick across sound so low intensity
focus a croissant use for imagine and to
combining both of this technology we are
able to complete control cavitation and
in a with computers and sort of a very
precise technology so how is temptation
control x SI so i would kind of go
through the different steps to first you
have acoustic wave that will cause
localized pressure situations in your
sample freedom since filtration will go
dissolved gas to form microscopic levels
this Bevers we go oscillate that one
point collapse and this process with
regenerate shear force at sa
technology-enabled precise control of
the generated shear force and so you can
see at the bottom the illustration when
you have the added up the pressure
fluctuation and at the bottoms of
variations in our radius of the
developer will go and then collapse
creating this inclusion shockwave and
RAM and share forth and so key to cover
is sa is his ability to precisely
control the generated shear force so
overall what are the key attributes of
the patented curve is a it's a
non-contact delivery of control focus on
acoustic energy and during the seed
treatment you have consistent support
number at you all the energy is focusing
three millimeter as we are working at
five hundred kilo app so the simulator
wavelength it's easier for possessing
biomed biomedical biological molecules
and small samples
and so you have a geometric a defocused
equity Canaries already all the energy
is delivered to the numbers you have no
waste of energy around and also they
sell have been optimized to transfer
this acoustic energy so overall it's a
highly patented technology with more
than 50 granted or pending patents and
cover the fa can be used in a wide range
of application so just sit graph will
show you some of them and we're
depending as we can finally control the
dedication to the shear force we can
move out from very low power from
universal improvement improving it is a
binding and then increasing the power on
the shelf or we can do some gina showing
supervises the gold standard for
signature info NGS some comedy ensuring
regen gold standard for cheap
applications and so we have also also
sell like these applications but today
whatever you want to focus is on the how
would the new the FA for two for the
extraction of DNA or RNA from SS these
numbers so how can we apply a fight with
these numbers fa with deliver active
position for from the critical sub-step
so what it means it means first we have
an acid-base depersonalization person is
emulsified it is entrant process as it
is done in aqueous solvent at in the
meantime as we remove the version with
an SI base tissue graduation many
bidders tissue digestion by protein is
dead because it should be very wary i
right the potential will have accessed
completely digested and to overall
improve extraction of DNA RNN so on the
next slide you can see some illustration
of active part in women role with a base
to power depopulation so at the bottom
we have a picture of FFP example before
and after anissa fication after the
investigation which you are getting a
milky solution so
white mist resolution of the beautified
passion so the chip inside is not
visible with it here at impact and so
when we size of small part in droplets
part of this edition and you can turn
the right you're getting very small
droplets less than 25 micron in diameter
so it makes a very stable version and
this process is done in aqueous solvent
to already removing all the passion in a
groove servant it's a gentle process no
heat no organic solvent and so it means
that we don't read the major proteins
that are still processing and so when we
disclose ink reversal we still have
impact put into that we can learn with
having with articles in it and so it's a
much more efficient cause incredible at
this stage it's also endpoint process so
completely operator independent doesn't
require any skills it done alkalies
instruments and so an illustration of
how efficient as this process is so you
can do a comparison of active versus
passive stuff in window roller so it is
a flow i found microscopic data of
different intersections the Ravel of
blue is proportional to the amount of
passing in the tissue on the left you
have untreated tissue and so with plenty
of passing on it on the right top
quality of the right you have a tissue
treated with an organic solvent and we
can see you still system blue so you
still add some passing on that in the
tissue even after the perfume words dead
in the middle you can see the same
tissue between treated with coryza and
you can see that insisted we have much
less blues meaning let much less person
left over in the tissue I mean that the
process of active Persian removal with
revised essay is both very gentle and
very efficient and so how this active
person we will translate into NGS great
DNA or our general and extraction from
the safety thumpers so I will then
present some data showing that we tested
the end an eye on frontage ability
and we were so sequin seed some samples
and compared um coverage so first data
is a real-time pcr so we choose a
housekeeping gene that the h and design
three primer sets of values land and we
compare so weird time pcr the DNA
extracted whisk arrived and with another
standard method so color is blue geo
dermatology hero and you can see for
different amplicon length from 59th base
pair up to 12 certificate expand that we
are getting much higher unpredictability
and DNA did with revised than with
automated so meaning that we're
educating these high quality diverse
friendliness that we did available for
education when working with a to extract
as a feed DNA extraction did so we did
the same with another housekeeping gene
action and wizard even broader set of on
pitkin from one on 109 betapace pair to
600 base pair and again we are seeing
the same type of performance meaning
that will arise to extract you are
getting much higher applicability and so
higher yield when you normalize to the
input of various key material so based
on this data we then carried out war
genome sequencing experiment and so you
can see some results here so how did we
design the experiment from the same
tissue we had searched for them at a
match fft blog so we extracted the DNA
from the fresh frozen tissue we also
extracted the DNA from the fft block
with two methods is the revised or
another standard method then this is our
area and go to see quantum so which was
a very low coverage on average connect
story highlight defense between
extraction techniques so as expected the
data extracted from France fresher than
trouble so in blue at the bottom polite
an offer a uniform coverage
the entire genome but you can say that
with a dnf rashid with revised you
almost have the same uniform coverage
across your genome so slightly more
galatians but still very good and to
encourage but with the other a technique
you can see that you have lots of
variations in the garage across the
genome so lots of pics and valet mean
that you don't get his uniform coverage
so that's really highlight I mean how
the quality of the DNA that you are
talking with in fact at the end the
quality of just wanting data and how
usable see sequencing data are we be so
another feature of the tread stripe F F
fitty make it is the ability to control
the size of the DNA fragments so by
default we don't find out the DNA at all
during the extraction process and so the
extracted DNA will be as loud as
possible and see to rate the band of how
it has been on bed and how does install
that's what we call option C that's at
the bottom that's what we rolled
exciting Jeremy DNA and here you have an
illustration so with a kind of recent
attack vblog we are getting up to 80 X
pair DNA DNA fragments after the
extraction from the ffv sample but we
also have understand a few need to arise
the option to five on the DNA after the
cross linked reversal so you steal your
seam with a mystified passing but then
we tell me in another ASI step we can
use the acoustic energy to find out the
DNA in the control way and to a size
suitable for NGS applications so it can
be total base pair of solid base pair
depending of type of libraries which one
to to constrict so we are you have
different options as part of a protocol
to by default we don't fragment DNA and
we can we can really prepare libraries
from for sequencing in a one cannot
wanted process so all what we saw with
the DNA kit also applied with our naked
we're also getting this NGS great RNA
informative these numbers so summer for
dinner you have to hunt way to us as
citizens each grade
my name yield the quad G&P stability and
so we first go on the applicability so
what applicability means it what is the
amount of RNA so what opportunity means
here you can see first we normalize
ready the amount of RNA before the
lecture pcr and so by normalizing the
amount of RNA we already see how up
together each RNA molecule is so that's
the graph on the left and so that is the
number of our animators after kaliesha
normalized by a bike to beat as input
and we can see that here the RNA amplify
with devices already I mean yes much
higher well pity a bird but then you
should take it into a into normalization
and so the initial qubit flow metric die
need you can see that overall when you
normalize by the input of SP tissue you
are getting like almost five hundred
percent improvement with revised
compared to tell Jenna so that's really
very large found that you can see over
like different tissue type so you can
see it until a tissue and so within the
tissue a we try to a big online by a
real-time qpcr sore on both 67 base pair
and 191 base pair and bowls case we see
large improvement in amphitheater RNA
molecules with revised combatants or
other standard methods we will be done
uterus tissue and again we see a higher
higher amount of complicate abbreviated
RNA molecules risk of ice but you can
see that it's not as dramatic with
uterus than with a twist in air or lying
tissue so that's a yes really would need
to keep in mind that there is large
variability across the different
affinity to type so performance will
depend both of the tissue type but also
under
storage of baking conditions so you will
see depending of your suppers with the
different relative improvement and
suitability for NGS dunst women so
another way to already assess the
quality of RNA molecules in the new
matrix called DV 200m so deep 200 is a
percentage of high month both 12
nucleotide at cpk DSS on the bio neither
chip so you can see an illustration air
so basically everything below the two
blue lines in both taller nucleotides
and so you're with db2 honored what
you're looking for as a percentage of
fragments between these two lines so
even our 30 publish on an objective
technical note evaluating and give
eternal as a matrix to assess and
equality for NGC continue and readjust
we're getting the highlight so people
are usually using ring members to assess
our inequality but actually there is no
correlation between wind numbers and
library need for three summers but there
is a very high correlation between DB
200 reviews and the librarian so their
conclusion was that DD 200 is a very
good matrix matrix to ssrn equality for
GS library constructions at whitaker
eyes you can see that until the example
and the Reliant issue we are getting
almost twenty percent improvement in the
digital honored video compared to other
standard methods and so the to extract
fe RNA get also imported suzanne's
design quality metrics and so when we
are saying that we really get is inject
great DNA RNA so that's in general data
as i show you but our customers and our
exs customer are seeing the same arm so
for example season paper has been
submitted from to a CR by a group at
dana-farber Cancer Institute in Boston
other just own quote from home the
abstract when they compared provides to
the standard method to Gentiles where
six times higher with less specimens
fail extractions gina was more readily
available for pizza amplification a new
reg of DNA fragment is hi GT go
backwards higher at multiple severe and
overall library complexity one higher so
all the data that i presently that's
also what our customers are seeing so
that's still a new technique and the new
product that so we we have already a
people publishing Baeza unseasoned
solution so just recently and the Nagas
muah lab at the University of Chicago
publish in clinical cancer research data
for advanced accounting base again for
the DNA extraction part of the tracks
right thank you so we just focus on the
razor as a partial removal tissue
hydration step but as your familia the
next next section Rocco for message is
not very is actually much more complex
so you have to collect the sample from
side you're starting with cosine curves
then transfer into a tube to remove the
bath in and then do the purification so
actually provides advice is full
walkthrough in a way that skrilla
scalable from one to nine six numbers
right now i will review each different
step and how we can address every
challenge in these steps so further how
we collect samples so you have different
type of samples they can get from a city
block and the to extract protocol has
been optimized for each sample type it's
completely compatible with biopsy curls
up to 1.2 millimeter in diameter so you
just load them in a quite Michael gebben
and process them to use it afternoon it
is a cobra convertible with course or a
sickness up to 25 mi cama but it also
compatible with the tissue montanum
slides with the tissue pitch and are we
going to model together but so overall
twice tractors in optimizing on a wide
range of tissue type so what's tissue
pitch it were your tools that we design
collect area of interest of an SF E and
a tissue side so it's very safe a simple
process low-cost with
Lester brother and some time and
variability so I 12 so firstly to teak
you determine the target of emm of
interest then we capture it by tweeting
the TV turn on the slide and then we
will relieve the dip it into a micro
tube from a party removal so next slide
you will see a movie it will last one
minute kind of showing us the use of the
Chesapeake so you won't hear any sound
doing this movie it's okay i will be
back online after at the end of Sigma V
and it will also have the chance to
participate in a short survey adjunctive
movie
you
you
so I'm back and so as you can see it's a
very simple tool that you can use to to
collect your an area of interest from
the former safety section slide so next
already part of the walkthrough is what
we just discussed so once you transfer
you some USF is not really into a micro
tube how you remove the bar scene we get
a process so we kind of went through the
clock technology but I would like more I
mean to regional most of the work flow
and so we have ready different where
forces examples with a FF it can be
signal processing for insist type of
tubes each stupa individually 2d barcode
its overall fighting its best numbers to
remove the path you know the protease k
digestion of the cotton grass or a done
in the same in the century but we can
also do some batch processing so system
swampers are processes in XPS plate
format it's etched with a 2d barcode and
with the higher soup instrument you can
process up to 98 examples in one hour
for the parking removal and rehydration
steps and so these citizen on provides
for castresana cable so that's what is
instrumented that with a worker and
delivery is a a question Angie so each
instrument the NIST traceable for the
calibration and so you have a wide range
of instruments so scalable from a single
sample to high school bit so just going
quickly to the product the product range
we have four singles single sample
processing we have the NQ 20 resource
more bench of instrument all those 20
then we have the equal 20 evil that can
process the 183 at a time and then for
higher supra to a larger batch we have
the e 220 that we process so up to 90
stompers but once about at the time
8220 that we process up to 96 numbers
that a table at a time so higher higher
throughput other enable batch process
all so to extract FFP kids are
compatible with older items per month
it's wedged a matter of determining
which instrument will feature work for
other you are a little bit of automation
require ala also the last part of a
complete ssv DNA RNA extraction workflow
is where the purification and again we
tracks watch you have many options it
can be user manual will be collins and
regions optimized to work with the AP
like that so it's included in our kit
and you have the current of the region's
optimized for the purification it's very
easy simple protocol that you're
probably all familiar with it can also
be silly or fully automated so we are
partnering with them with a company that
pretty develop a completely automated
solution with big base to education and
you have to develop photos automation is
a sameer to make it to 12 sample at a
time or fully automated an integrated on
the deep in any robots so again the menu
option need mini level of kisses
customization and finally we also have a
total nucleic acid extraction solution
available so from the same FFP sample
will be able to extract both DNA and RNA
in a serious way and getting both cases
very high quality and jets grade nucleic
acids and I'm sort of rocker which is to
extract 50 and the geeky succession so
it will be standardized robots workflow
for a gr8 UK gated accession from a
security issue key is a highly efficient
SI base parking remover so this active
part in removal robust optimized in
aqueous buffer so no heat no hazardous
against advanced with preserved proteins
be further the colloquial forum it is a
complete tissue hydration to be
neighbors
complete protein C digestion three
Twitter's in maximum maximal nucleoside
lead and more important quality at the
end what you get is NGS grade weekly
guess it's highly arbitrary bergkamp
late and bias co-writer the genome a
deep universally demanding demanding
applications like PG a free were genome
sequencing so some of our key customers
already doing this type of applications
that's really where this is huge
importance of getting this NGS great DNA
RL mmm so if we have one takeaway note
is that extracted nucleic acid
suitability for IGS a petition is
directly related to the departmentation
technology at base a base active part in
the world where the universe and
generate nucleic acid extraction so
thank you for ion channel original we
take some questions thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on a question and answer session
i would like to remind our audience how
to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window will try to
answer as many questions as we can and
our first question is why is active
paraffin removal so different so why is
it so she found that's really the way
that it's only a crystal gone so
compared to all other technique data
pretty harsh is a hate some type of
organic serve and the fact that we are
able to that in aqueous buffer at home
Tapia geo means that we really preserve
both the DNA and the proteins during his
active power forward step and so when we
go to the hotel to digestion by protein
esta we have see very well rehydrate
tissue matrix that would be a table
substrate for the protonated says we
were very he
when I put in state digestion and then
as we didn't read them damaged the
cross-link we are very efficient cutting
grass or so we don't have any like
single peptide still on the DNA do you
think that we are getting a really good
template than 440 Mary's when the for
perimeter armed highway construction or
PCR is it compatible with all kavars
instruments yes so it's compatible with
all the co instrument that we have right
now on the market and so yes it's
covered with all the concerns that you
can use for comfort for all the library
preparation for NGS so also in terms
that you're using to 25 module DNA RNA
which compatible with instruments as
well with all the instruments are useful
for cheap again at the curl of the
process localized as a technology and so
what's that we were to acquire this is
this a technology to to remove them the
passion arm and so that the same base
brick of technology that can be with
fries for multiple positions he is
available or in beta access so yes it's
a very diverse so the DNA kit has been
available for almost one year under our
naked adjusting ladies as well as a
protocol for total you can get the
expression and two as well as a tissue
pitch so the way to collect SSP tissue
from site is also available which
standard method is used for extraction
too that's the most common techniques
that use bio labs yeah you can probably
guess which signature it is and um the
smallest area you could take from the
person slide is so it's so it depends
really what the question is if the
question is with a smaller that you can
collect with the tissue peach we have
like almost one millimeter one or two
millimeter resolution than the question
is rhesus type of resolutions which like
a few square millimeter tissue will
really you get enough DNA or RNA out for
downstream application it will depend of
course the tissue type we have many
nuclei are not so many nuclei so I can't
really and give a black and white answer
it will depend also of those other kind
of storage condition of the slide
because when slider still too long you
can start with some degradation it's
really fun for RNA okay how long can
only be preserved in ffpe agenda should
depend up many parameters how it could
be and so how's the tissue has been
correct because if it's there be sure to
be on bed if you stay at home TT on the
bench you will see lot of degradation so
it's been like fresh frozen just after
collect and then I began passing we'd
get much higher pitch RNA and then how
the f á p block is though it is the
other block which part in the air to
protect such issue oh you'd start on
poverty it is the one slide so many
questions if you have the choice better
to worker with a fresh block that you
and receive blogs that you know an order
workflow and the embedding workflow
buttons as you you don't have choice so
that we can rock with yes blog as long
as a few years is there been a proper am
store on Tom better if the kitchen kick
setting the sanitation so the TV is
actually quite neutral so for those
familiar with a garage process we as we
are what we go to FF fiber into our tube
to kind of control this dedication ad
actually so we keep this ffi but we just
started tissue big just really a way to
transfer the SS these numbers it won't
really affect education by by itself
meaning that cavitation is still
controlled by the by the SS fiber that
including all our micro chips that are
part of the to extract kit
like if minimal fish aquatic Lee
workable with AFA its again has it some
question as a working from a from SSP
tissue slides twist depend of the tissue
type III depends of the nuclei density
so so yeah we are we are the people
working with very small quantity at all
sweet depend yeah that's many variables
are the hid real a very different
depending of a type of tissue that who
you're starting with okay next question
can i use raw material samples from
laser microdissected tissue or do i need
high amount starting material it's
working with both so we have people
working with a low material from
typically yes HTM about people or
vehicles so again depend a lot of what
you want to do downstream you want to do
like to see a free virgin sequencing you
will have to start with kind of large
cost to get enough DNA to do your
application if you want to do some
targeted panels like a message we can
work and yeah you can work with much
more or somebody input hey art issues
that had been put on slides and covered
by person for long periods suitable for
your technology in theory yes meaning
that already developed it should be to
collect the tissue from the slide but
again what do you mean by long period
and also what was a storage condition
that's kind of a key parameter if it was
I mean some studio I've shown that stir
in a fridge a design I'd metadata that
from number two what was humidity of the
room that OC spider that will have an
impact on the RNA quality and currently
in some case HP for our lights vaguely
you cannot really get regardless of
expression technique if the sample is
not installed properly and
too long you can't get as a great leader
to acquire four NGS application all
right when in the protocol is their
tissue rehydration so tissue rehydration
is just after actually almost in the
same time similar gen use to the
departing with more water so when you
start with the FF EDM tissue in the
garage microchip so you have seized
aqueous solvent you will deliver the
acoustic energy you have to sharing so
that we remove the bathroom and as you
remove the passengers hydrophobic in the
meantime you push the aqueous buffer
into the tissue and then you have 62
hydration so that's really cute n use
remove the passion and we I delight in
the meantime you remove the hydrophobic
passing and you push the buzzer into the
tissue can the AFA process we apply to a
DNA extraction from old bones so can be
applied to the gene expression from all
bond so yes it's a kind of a different
where that and actually I can answer
that separately in an email so yes we
have solutions based on kind of 30
privatization to work with with bones
it's kind of it's not working right with
this 50 tits conversely bikes or
solutions or but yeah I can try that
later so we have time for one more
question it is can we extract viral DNA
with respect so yes so the currents have
been optimized to work with our side of
DNA so yes we get by or DNA issue of
something you ought to figure tissue
goat yes so unfortunately we are out of
time I want to thank the audience for
their interesting questions and
participation in today's event we will
respond in writing to those who did not
get to you today I would also like to
thank our sponsor cove Aris for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available on
demand for up to six months and
indefinitely on lab roots webinar
th you'll receive an email from lab
groups alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to for that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live in it see you next time bye